it's 1.8 billion pounds for the Health
Service where does it coming from
well one of the great advantages of
having more people in work than ever
before the lowest unemployment since the
1970s wages growing their fastest rate
for a decade businesses looking to
invest in the UK is the economy is
working we want to make sure it works
for people and that means getting money
into the NHS Boris has made absolutely
clear he wants to see that money
reaching the frontline of the NHS and
that's what this commitments about this
20 extra hospitals getting equipment
making sure that people see that money
working for them yeah I mean they're not
new hospital this is improvement to
exist it's improve as hospitals that we
that we need to see as say new equipment
repairs upgrades things that people will
see in their everyday lives so where is
the money coming from well as I say the
money is coming from
economic growth this is why it's so
important that we keep the economy
growing that we do things like the
northern powerhouse to make sure the
economy is growing not just in London in
the southeast but all over the country
the middle because growth it 2009 levels
toward only well this this all these
decisions all the things that Boris is
announcing about Crossrail for the North
Midlands engine free ports this is all
about that economic growth and that's
what gives us the tax receipts that
enables us to spend money on those
20,000 extra police officers and the NHS
and the Education Funding those those
domestic policy commitments that Boris
has made so this is future growth this
isn't growth it's currently these places
this is growth we're gonna have to wait
for in some point in the future
otherwise it means we're either going to
have to be borrowing more which seems to
be the case otherwise we'd have to see
income tax going up our corporation tax
going up know that if you want to go to
a party that's going to do you know high
taxes and unaffordable boring when asked
the labour force in the low party
committing to a thousand billion of
unfunded commitments so a conservator at
the moment isn't it but the point the
point is that the decision that we made
in government to get the economy
imbalance so we're getting economic
growth better
a lot of our other global competitors
not as much as we would want and that's
why the Boris is talking about pump
priming the economy getting those things
in place in the north in the Midlands in
yes in London and also in the other
parts of the UK to make sure we've got
the grace to fund the public services
that we that we want I mean the Nuffield
trust describes this as a drop in the
ocean the Health Foundation says that we
need six billion points to get the NHS
back on track 6 billion pound repair
bill currently existing I mean 1.8
billion pounds in an additional funding
will be welcomed but it comes nowhere
close to getting the Health Service to
where it needs to the health service is
better funded now than ever before in
its history and you know 1.8 billion is
nothing to be sniffed at is a
significant commitment on top of what
was already a very significant
commitment to the NHS Boris has made it
absolutely clear the NHS is a priority
we want to make sure it is you know
ready to serve the the people properly
that means investing in it that means
investing in the front line so people
can feel the improvements in their daily
lives that's what he's committed to and
that's what we're doing I wonder if we
can talk about the bracken by-election
just for a moment I mean that must've
been a huge disappointment particularly
for for yourself the new chairman of the
party that you couldn't hold on to that
seat and you know sitting with the
majority of just one yeah of course it's
a disappointing we don't like losing
elections I don't like losing elections
we we campaign in these elections
because we want to win we came close in
this one my frustration and I know you
brought up with Claire my real
frustration is that 3,000 people who
voted clearly because they wanted brexit
delivered have now got a Lib Dem MP
who's gonna make her you know calls to
try and prevent breaks I think they
don't believe you when they say that
you're going to deliver brexit well they
should actually [ __ ] well they should
because I tell you now we are going to
deliver brexit by the 31st of October
fact so there's got no ifs no gonna know
if it's going to happen if it doesn't
happen believe as I no ifs no buts we
are going to if it doesn't end up in
reject design that so the point is if it
doesn't happen the collapse in
confidence in democracy in a democracy
you don't pick
choose which election results you abide
by we had a referendum we made it clear
both sides the referendum made it clear
that it would be delivered the House of
Commons voted to trigger article 50 and
article 50 means that you leave at a
date with or without a deal the House of
Commons voted for that and that is what
everyone provides all that we were going
to get a deal no no no no no no article
50 is clear article 50 is clear if you
cannot get a deal you leave anyway and
the majority of losing a part of all 50
did so believing that No Deal was a
possibility article 50 is explicit at
the end of the process if you have not
agreed a deal you leave anyway the House
of Commons including Jonathan Ashworth
you had on earlier voted France call 50
explicit not implicit explicit in that
is leaving without a deal if one cannot
be agreed the Prime Minister is trying
to get a deal and if we can get rid of
the undemocratic backstop we may be able
to leave with a deal but if not we are
going to leave on the 31st of all tape
which is it we see there seems to be
some of isolation in the messaging
coming from Downing Street particularly
this week as to you know where know the
likelihood of new dealers on the one
hand you've got the Prime Minister
telling me that it's a million-to-one of
a chance you know we had Rishi sir she
sue knock on the shore last week saying
that they got that No Deal preparations
are no the government's number-one
priority
I mean frankly those two don't tally no
they absolutely do they absolutely do a
million to one that it's gonna happen so
the point is the Prime Minister's makes
our number one priority Prime Minister
has made it clear that we want to leave
with a deal and if the EU Candice can
demonstrate a degree of pragmatism and
flexibility that can be done but we're
also making it absolutely clear because
we are going to leave on the 31st of
October mm-hmm and if we have to leave
without a deal that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna make sure that leaving
without a deal is deliverable in my in
my former job in index you that was my
job to make sure across government
preparations were in place those
preparations are being enhanced because
we want to make sure that if we can't
get a deal that we are ready to leave
anyway two billion points for New Deal
preparations two billion pounds roughly
at for the Health Service an additional
twenty third what recruiting 20,000
Eppley
officers when did the conservators
realized that austerity wasn't the right
policy the decisions that we made to get
the public finances in balance were
always meant to be in place until the
public finances were in balance the
public finances are now in an infinitely
better place than what we inherited
maybe in a better place death is still
rise from the economic car crash that we
inherited from labor and we said about
repairing that that wasn't easy but
we're now in a place where the economy
is performing significantly better much
better and that enables us to do what
all governments want to do which is to
make sure that the public services on
which people rely are in in in good
order and that means that money into the
NHS and policing and education and
infrastructure because these are things
which we know important we've always
known them to be important and the
economic decisions that we had to take
in the aftermath of Labour's ineptitude
we had to do to get the economy in the
kind of place where we can spend money
moving billions of pounds off the
spending has already been set up by
Boris Johnson as I say two billion for
an ordeal two billion for the health
saps you know look me in the eyes and
with a straight face tell me that there
isn't going to be a general election
this year there isn't there is not going
we are not going to initiate a general
election we have elections all the time
we have elections very election II right
now with all this spending going on know
what we've got is a new prime minister
who during the leadership campaign made
a number of explicit commitments and he
is setting about delivering on those
commitments the Prime Minister's making
govern their promises is a good thing
and that's what we're doing and what we
are what we are insuring is that the the
the things that people have told us in
the hustings around the country in the
online hustings that we that we had
during the leadership the things they
told us mattered to them we are
delivering on and that is the good old
traditional priorities the British
people they want the NHS to work they
want to feel safe in their streets they
want to see the money getting to the
frontline in health policing and in
education that is what we are doing I
just wonder what spear have you just one
final question on your role as chairman
of the party of course you're not the
first person of colour to hold the
position Baroness party was
but I just wonder how you feel that that
you'd of pull the chemo that suggested
you know that 54% of conservative
rank-and-file believe that Islam is
generally a threat to the British Way of
life are we going to get an independent
inquiry into Islamophobia within the
conservative party two things that that
survey was of people who claim to be
party members we didn't share our
membership data with the polling company
so we we're not sure that they
necessarily are the point is we have
always taken a robust line with people
who have said inappropriate things or
inappropriate baby but we will always do
that it's that we wait an independent
inquiry there will be that yes there
will be and that will be specific to
Islamophobia and not just a lot of forms
and races so in the pursuit so one of
the things that we need to one of the
things we need to get is the definition
of that and so specifically on that
point we will be guided by the formal
definition of Islamophobia but the point
is we do and we'll always take firm
action with anyone who steps outside the
boundaries of appropriate behavior